สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูเรียมสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกๆคนด้วยสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครู
นิคะวันนี้เราเจอกันวันอะไร
คะวันนี้ครับที่อเมริกานะเป็นวันอาทิตย์
อืวันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาคมครับ
อืปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
[เพลง]
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 โอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะที่
อเมริกาตอนนี้นะครับเวลามา
21  29
น
21  29 นาที
ใช่กำลังจะคิดอยู่ว่าเขียนเอ๊ะ 21 หรือ
ว่าเขียน 9 ครับใช่โอค 2 เป็นเวลาที่
อเมริกาที่เมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่อืตัวเลขสวย
มยคะครูนิ 9  .29 เลขสวยใช่ 9  9 ฟังคน
ไทยฟังเราก็รู้สึกว่าเออมันเป็นเลขเป็น
เลขดีเพราะเหมน 9 คือคนไทยก็ใช้ว่าเลข 9
แล้วก็เหมือนกับ 9 เดินไป 9 หน้าก็คือให้
มันดีๆขึ้นอ๋อดีขึ้นก็คือเหมือนเหมือน
เดินไปข้างหน้าใช่ก็ก้าวไปอืพูดถึงเลข 9
ใช่เลข 9 ครูนิคิดว่าเป็นเลขเลขคือเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรเป็นเลขนำโชคของคนไทยหลายๆคน
เหมือนกันอืเป็นเลขนำโชคของครูนิกด้วยยคะ
เลข 9 จริงๆแล้วสำหรับครูนิกเนี่ยครูนิก
ไม่ครูนิกเฉยๆกับเลข 9 อืครูนิกน่าจะไม่
อะไรกับเลข 9 เท่าไหร่
คือคุณนิกถ้าพูดเกี่ยวกับเลขนำโชคเนี่ย
คือคุนิกจะมีความคิดแปลกๆคือคุณนี่แค่รู้
สึกว่าเลข 9 ใช่ว่าฟังแล้วความหมายมันดี
ว่าก้าวก้าวหน้าเหมือนมันดีขึ้นแต่มันก็
เป็นความคิดที่คิดว่าคนไทยเกือบทุกคนน่ะ
ก็คิดแบบนั้นทำให้ครูนิกคิดว่าแล้วถ้าครู
นิกเป็นเหมือนเค้าแสดงว่ายกตัวอย่างว่า
ประเทศไทยมีคนไทยทั้งหมด 60 ล้านคนอืแล้ว
50 ล้านคนเลขนำโชคหรือเลขที่โชคดีคือเลข
9 เลข 9 มันก็ไม่ดีลคือกได้คิดว่าก็แย่ง
โชคดีไปหมดเลยสิ
อ๋อก็คือหลายๆายคนที่เขาแบบชอบเลข 9
เพราะเขาคิดว่าเออเลข 9 โชคดีใช่มยใชใช่
คุณนิคิดว่าเออไม่เพราะว่าทุกคนแบ่งโชคดี
กันหมดแล้ว
ใช่แล้วโชคดีของครูนิกคิดว่าเป็นตัวเลข
อะไรคืออ่ะถ้าเป็นของครูนิกเนี่ยครูนิกจะ
ชอบเลข
ใช่ครูนิกมีเหตุผลมั้ยทำไมชอบเลข 5 คือ
จริงๆเนี่ยคุณนิกเนี่ยชอบเลข 5 เพราะว่า
เมื่อก่อนนะตอนเด็กๆรู้สึกว่าจะเจออะไร
ที่มีเลข 5 อยู่ด้วยบ่อยๆอืครูนิเกิดวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่จริงๆอ่ะครูนิเกิดวันที่ 8
อ๋อเดือนอะไรคะเดือน 5 มั้ย
ไม่จริงๆเลข 8 ก็คือเป็นเลขนำโชคเป็นเลข
ที่ทำให้ครูนิกโชคดีคือเลขที่ครูนิกชอบ
และคิดว่าเป็นเลขนำโชคเนี่ยคือเอาโชคดีมา
ให้ครูนี้ิก็จะมีเลข 5 แล้วก็เลข 8
อ๋อเตรียมว่าครูนิกต้องเล่าแล้วแหละว่า
โชคดีที่ครูนิกได้จากเลข 5 กับเลข 8 คือ
อะไรคือของครูนิกเนี่ยอ่ะะอันนี้นะถ้าเลข
5 เนี่ยก็คือเวลาคือเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยเมื่อก่อนคือคุณนิจะชอบดูไพ่แบบดู
ดวงอ่ะทาโล่ยิบซีอะไรอย่างงี้เหรอใช่สมัย
แบบเรียนมหาลัยกับเพื่อนก็จะไปดูว่างๆแบบ
1 เดือนแล้วก็เฮ้ยไปดูดวงอ่ะไปออไปดไป
คุยคุยกับหมอดูเลยใช่มไม่ใช่ดูใน YouTube
ดูใช่ไปเจอเป็นคนเลยแล้วเขาก็จะเหมือนกับ
มีเป็นไพ่ทาโร่ใช่มยก็คือเป็นไพ่ให้เลือก
หรือบางที่เนี่ยเขาก็จะให้เลือกเหมือน
เป็นตัวเลขแล้วคุณนิก็จะเลือกตัวเลขที่
มันมีเหมือนกับ
55  50 อะไแบบเนี้ยเยอะมากกว่าแล้วคุณ
นิกรู้สึกว่าพอเปิดไพ่ออกมาเนี่ยเปิดไพ่
ทาโร่แล้วมันเออมันความหมายดีแค่นั้นเอง
อก็เลยแบบชอบนี่แหละเลข 5 เลข 5 นี่แหละ
โอเคที่สุดใชใช่ก็คือโอเคที่สุดคือเรา
ต้องมีโชคดี
เ้อนั่นแหละอ้าแล้วแล้วเลข 8 น่ะมาจาก
ความเชื่อของคนอื่นหรือว่าของครูนิเอง
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยเลข 8 เนี่ยที่ชอบคือไม่
ได้มีอะไรเลยแค่เพราะว่ามันเป็นเลขวัน
เกิดแค่นั้นเองแล้วเลข 8 เนี่ยคุณนิกรู้
สึกว่าครูนิกแค่รู้สึกว่าคุณนิกชอบเลข 8
เป็นการส่วนตัวเพราะเลข 8 มันเหมือนเป็น
ตัว a
Infinity ใช่อืใช่ของเรียมก็แบบเล่นเลข 8
ก็แบบเออถ้าเกิดถามว่าเรียมชอบเลขอะไร
เรียมก็ตอบว่าเลข 8 นะอือแล้วตอนนี้ที่
กำลังคิดอยู่อาจจะเป็นเพราะว่าได้ยินคน
อื่นพูดว่าอ๋อเลข 8 ดีมันเป็นแบบ
Infinity เราก็เลยอาจจะจำมาว่าอ๋อเลข 8
เลข 8 เลข 8 แล้วแบบเวลาที่แบบเราแบบดู
แล้วก็ออเลข 8 เออชอบเออชอบเลข 8 เออแต่
มันคงมีเหตุผลแหละว่าแบบเออเคยฟังมาคน
อื่นๆบอกว่าดีแล้วเวลาเขาถามเราไม่รู้ว่า
จะตอบว่าอะไรอ่าโอคเราก็เลยแบบอ่ะเลือก
เลือกสัก 1 อันออๆเลข 8 เลข 8
ค่ะจริงๆอีกตัวเลขนึงเนี่ยคุณนิกจะบอกว่า
เป็นเลขนำโชคก็ไม่ใช่ 100% คืออันนี้แค่
รู้สึกว่ามันมีอะไรเกิดขึ้นเกี่ยวกับตัว
เลขนี้เยอะเหมือนกันคือเลข 2
อือื
โหมีอะไรเกิดขึ้นกับเลข 2 คะครูนิกคือแค่
รู้สึกว่าคือครูนิกเนี่ยเกิดวันอังคารวัน
อังคารก็คือวันที่ 2 เหมือนกับว่าเป็น
เหมือนจันทร์จันทร์อังคารพุธอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยอังคารก็คือเหมือนกับวันที่ 2 ของ
สัปดาห์อื
แล้วคุณนิกอ่ะมานั่งดูเนี่ยเวลาคุณนิกได้
งานใหม่เนี่ยเ่ะวันที่เริ่มทำงานจะเป็น
วัน
อังคารจะไม่วันอังคารก็จะต้องเป็นวันที่
มีเลข 2
อ๋อเออคุณนี้ก็เลยคิดว่าเออมันเกี่ยวอะไร
กับเลข 2
บ่อยอออใชู่เหมือนครับครูนิกมีความเชื่อ
เรื่องตัวเลขครูนิกเคยแบบซื้อล็อตเตอรรี่
มั้ยเคยแต่ไม่
ถูกเออเคยแต่ไม่ถูกก็เลยแบบอะไรวะคือครู
นิกเนี่ยจะไม่จะน้อยมากที่จะซื้อ
ล็อตเตอรี่แล้วได้
รางวัลอันนั้นจะเป็นตัวอย่างเดียวเกี่ยว
กับตัวเลขที่จะไม่ค่อยไปสนใจเท่าไหร่อื
เออใช่เรียมก็เหมือนกันไม่สนใจเลยเพราะ
ว่าเคยซื้อแล้วแบบไม่ถูกไม่ถูกหวยไม่ถูก
ล็อตเตอรี่อก็เลยแบบไม่สนใจจแล้วเวลาที่
มีคนถามว่าซื้อล็อตเตอรรี่ซื้อหวยมยเรียม
ก็จะคิดนะว่าคนอื่นๆเค้าเอาตัวเลขเอาตัว
เลขแล้วเอาเงินไปซื้อเค้าเอามาจากไหนเ้า
คิดคิดตัวเลข 1  2 แล้วก็ไปซื้อคือเรียม
แบบไม่รู้อ่ะแือเรียมรู้สึกแบบงงมากกับ
สิ่งนี้ครับอื
เออก็เลยแบบแบบไม่ไม่ค่อยไม่ค่อยได้มี
อะไรเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขเลยอ๋ออือ่ะเดี๋ยวนะ
แล้วเมื่อกี้ที่ครูเรียมบอกว่าครูเรียม
ชอบเลข 8 แล้วมีเลขอะไรอีกที่ครูเรียมรู้
สึกว่าเป็นเลขที่นำโชคเหมือนเอาความโชคดี
มาให้เอาความโชคดีมาให้หรอคือเรียมก็แบบ
เรียมเรียมไม่เคยแบบเก็บสถิติเลยอ่ะว่า
เลข 1 เจอ 1 กี่ครั้งแล้วดีเจอ 2  1  2  3
ครั้งแล้วดีเรียมเรียมไม่เคยคิดเกี่ยวกับ
เรื่องตัวเลขแล้วแบบเวลาทำงานวันแรกวัน
อะไรเรียมก็ไม่
จำไม่จำเรียมก็เลยแบบเวลาคนถามก็แบบชอบ
เลขอะไรเลข 8 แต่ถามว่าเลข 8 ทำให้โชคดีม
เรียมก็แบบไม่
รู้เพราะอาจจะไม่ได้คิดเรื่องแบบไโชคดี
หรือไม่ดีโชคดีหรือไม่ดีอะไรแบบเนี้ย
อืแต่ก็ชอบฟังนะชอบฟังคนอื่นเล่าแต่ของ
ตัวเองเนี่ยก็คือไม่จำลืม
ลืม
เออแล้วพอเราพูดเกี่ยวกับเลขนำโชคเนี่ยมา
สักพักละทีนี้เนี่ยครูเรียมมีมว่าที่เป็น
เลขที่ครูเรียมไม่
ชอบใช้คำว่าไม่ชอบนะอื
อืไม่ชอบหรออือ
โหไม่ได้มีอะไรเลยในนี้ไม่ได้มีอ๋อน่าจะ
เป็นอ๋อเลข 13 อ้าทำไมครับน่าจะเป็น 13
เพราะแบบฟังมาจากคนอื่นอืฟังมาจากคนอื่น
คนอื่นๆบอกว่า
เอ้ยห้องห้องหรือว่าอะไรที่เป็น 13 อ่ะ
ไม่ดีอือฮึไม่ดีิมก็เลยแบบเวลาที่เราไปไป
นอนโรงแรมแบบไปต่างจังหวัดที่ไม่ได้อยู่
บ้านนะก็ต้องไปนอนโรงแรมเราก็คิดนะห้อง
ห้องเบอร์ 13 หรือเปล่าอือฮึเพราะว่าเรา
ดูในทีวีไงดูในหนังไงแล้วก็ห้องเบอร์ 13
เนี่ยจะมีผี
เออใช่ก็เลยแบบน่าจะเป็นเลข 13 นี่แหละ
ที่คิดว่าแบบไม่
ชอบก็มาจากคนอื่นนะไม่ได้มาจากตัวเอง
เออใช่แล้วครูนิล่ะมีตัวเลขอะไรมั้ยที่
รู้สึกว่าอ้อไม่ดีเลยครูนิกอ่ะเอาจริงๆ
น่ะครูนิกไม่
มีไม่มีตัวเลขไหนที่คุณนิไม่ชอบคือจะใช้
คำว่าใช้แค่ว่าไม่ได้รู้สึกอะไรมากกว่า
เลขส 3 เนี่ยครูนิดก็เฉยๆคือก็ได้ยินว่า
เลข 13 เนี่ย
เป็นเลขไม่ดีหรืออย่างที่ครูเรียมบอกว่า
ถ้าเกิดไปโรงแรมแล้วได้ห้องที่มีเลข 13
หรือ 1  3 อยู่ด้วยกันจะมีผีอันนั้นน่ะ
คุณนิกก็มาคิดว่าคือผีอ่ะถ้าผีจะมาหลอก
อ่ะเค้าก็ไปห้อง 14 ได้เค้าก็ไปห้อง 12
ได้มันไม่ใช่ว่าห้อง 13 อย่างเดียวคือแค่
คุณที่คิดว่าถ้าจะโดนผีหลอกอ่ะอยู่ตรงไหน
อ่ะมันก็เค้าก็มาหลอก
ใช่อืก็ใช่นะแต่ว่าสำหรับคนที่แบบเชื่อ
เชื่อมากๆ
เออโรงแรมก็ไม่ได้มีห้องเบอร์ 13 อไม่ได้
มีชั้น 13 นะกดลิฟขึ้นไปแล้วก็ 10  11  12
14 อืไม่มีชั้น 13 ใช่ก็คุณนิคิดว่าเป็น
เพราะถ้าในประเทศไทยนะที่ไม่มีอ่ะเพราะคน
ต่างชาติเนี่ยเา้าจะเชื่อเกี่ยวกับเลข 13
เยอะ
อืมอืใช่ก็ทำให้ทุกคนสบายใจไม่มีดีกว่าใช
เออไม่มีดีกว่าแต่คือมันไม่มีเพราะเหมือน
กับเค้าไม่เห็นตัวเลขแต่อย่าลืมว่าถ้าเรา
นับจริงๆอ่ะมีอชเมันก็คือชั้น 13 มันแค่
ไม่มีตัวเลขแค่นั้นเองใช่ๆเออนั่นแหละแต่
ว่าอะไรที่สบายใจอ่ะเนาะมันก็เป็นเกี่ยว
กับธุรกิจเค้าอ่ะถ้าเกิดว่าเค้ายังมีเลข
13 มันก็อาจจะทำให้คนไม่อยากไป
อืแม่ครูนิกเนี่ยไม่ชอบเลข
6 ทำไมคะคือที่แม่ครูนิกไม่ชอบเลข 6
เพราะเหมือนกับชื่ออ่ะคือมันหกอ่ะหกหมด
เลยแม่ครูนิกจะชอบพูดแบบนี้อ๋อเหมือนน้ำ
อย่างงี้หรอน้ำที่แบบปึ๊บแล้วก็แบบอุ๊ย
น้ำ 6 น 6 เออใช่แม่คูนิก็จะไม่ชอบถ้ามี
เลขที่เป็นเลข 6 เค้าก็จะแบบไม่เอาอ่ะ
เปลี่ยนอือ๋อเหมือนน้ำหกก็คือออกไปหมดเลย
ไม่เหลืออะไรเลยใชใช่ๆคือถ้าซื้อของอ่ะ
ถ้าเป็นเลข 6 เนี่ยมันทำอะไรไม่ได้อยู่
แล้วอืเพราะว่าถ้าสมมุติเรา
ไปเราไปที่ห้างแล้วก็ไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
แล้วเบอกว่าออทั้งหมด 1,6 บาทค่ะอืครนี้
ก็หยิบไงหยิบช็อกโกแลตมาจ่ายมา
ให้แม่ก็บอกว่าตีมือจะให้จ่ายเพิ่ม
ทำไมเออคือเหรอแม่คุณนี้ก็จะทำอะไรไม่ได้
เเออปล่อยไปแต่ถ้าเราเลือกได้ว่าสมมุติ
นั่งรถทัวร์นั่งเครื่องบินที่นั่งเลือก
ได้ก็จะไม่เอาที่มีเลข 6
อ๋อหหแบบนี้เชื่อมากๆเลยนะเนี่ยใช่อืนั่น
แหละอือแต่สำหรับเรี่มนี่เป็นคนที่ไม่ได้
คิดอะไรเลยคือแม่ของคุณนิกอ่ะเค้าจะเป็น
คนที่เค้าเรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะเป็นคนไทยไๆที่เ
มีไทมากมากจะคูนิกจะไม่ใช้คำว่าหัวโบราณ
แต่เขาจะมีความเชื่อของคนไทยที่เหมือน
อย่างเลข 9 ที่คนไทยมว่าดีเพราะมันก้าว
หน้า 6 ก็คือหหมดมันล้มมันหอืือใช่เรมคิด
ว่ามันอาจจะมีเหตุผลมาจากอะไรสักอย่างนี่
แหละแต่ว่าเวลาที่คนพูดพูดต่อๆกันมา
เรื่อยๆเราก็แบบเออเชื่อเชื่อเชื่อเพราะ
ว่ามีคนพูดเยอะเหมือนเรียมอ่ะอืคนบอกว่า
เลข 8 ดีเดมก็เลยออๆๆเลข 8 ทั้งที่ความ
จริงก็ไม่ได้คิดอะไรเลยแล้วก็บอกว่าเลข 13
ไม่ดีเดีมก็เออๆๆ 13 ไม่ดีทั้งที่ความ
จริงก็ไม่ได้คิดอะไรเลยนะ
อ๋อแสดงว่าครูเรียมเนี่ยไม่ได้อะไรเลย
เกี่ยวกับตัวเลขไม่ไม่คิดเลยคือครูนิกอ่ะ
ก็คือคุณนิกแค่รู้สึกว่ายกตัวอย่างว่า
จริงๆเนี่ยคครูนิกตัวเลขอะไรคุณนิก็โอเค
หมดแต่แค่ถ้ามันเป็นเลข 8 เลข 2 เลข 5
ถ้าเห็นแล้วคุณนิก็สเอ้ยรู้สึกดีชอบเลข
นี้เออแค่นั้นแต่ถ้าไม่ได้ก็เออช่างั้นอ
อืวันนี้เราคุยกันตัวกับตัวเลขนี่แบบก็
เยอะมากแล้วนะเยอะจนหมดไปลา
หมดเวลาแล้วเหรอไม่ใช่เฮ้ยเหลืออีก 4
นาทีใช่ตกใจเนี่ยเห็นมยเลข 5 เป็นเนี่ย
ตอนนี้ 45 เป็นการบอกว่ายังไม่หมดเห็นะ
โชคดีออใช่คนนี้ก็แบบโชคดีเรายแบบเวลาถ้า
เกิดนักเรียนได้ดูคลิปที่มีเรียมอยู่ใน
นี้นะนักเรียนก็จะเห็นบ่อยๆว่าเรียมเนี่ย
บวกเวลาผิดบ่อย
ๆแล้วก็แบบเอ๊ะเหลืออีก 10 นาทีใช่มั้ย
เหลือแบบ
อ๋อบวกเลขแบบ
ผิดบวกเลขผิดไปหมดนี่ไงก็เลยคิดว่าเออตัว
เลขไม่ได้อะไรกับตัวไม่จำจริงๆเรื่องตัว
เลขไม่จำนักเรียนก็เห็นนะเวลาเอาอะไรนะ
เอามาบวกลบกันน่ะนักเรียนก็อาจจะคิดนะว่า
ครูเรียมมันยากขนาดนั้นเลย
เหรอถามว่าจริงๆบางคนถ้าเกี่ยวกับตัวเลข
อ่ะมันก็ยากบางคนก็ไม่ชอบไงมันก็เลยแบบ
เออเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขไม่อยากจะคิดเยอะแล้ว
อืออืแต่แต่ก็พอพอพูดถึงตัวเลขเพราะครู
เรียมบอกว่าครูเรียมได้ยินหลายคนพูดว่า
เออเลข 13 ไม่ดี
เลข 9 เนี่ยดีเลข 8  infinit อะไรพวก
เนี้ยเคยได้ยินอะไรอีกมยเกี่ยวกับตัวเลข
จากคนอื่นหรือที่ไม่ใช่เกี่ยวกับความ
เชื่อของคนไทย
โหไม่ใช่ความเชื่อของคนไทย
ก็ศุกร์ที่ 13 ก็ไปแล้วนะแล้วก็มีตัวเลข
อะไรอีกอ่ะมก็ได้ยินมาว่ามีหลายคนชอบเลข
7 ทำไมทำไมใช่เค้าก็คิดว่าแบบเหมือนเป็น
ตัวเลขโชคดีสำหรับบางคนนะอชอบเลข7ค้ายกับ
เลข 9 เลยที่แบบทำให้แบบดีขึ้นดีขึ้นดี
ขึ้นอาจจะเป็นเพราะเลข 7 มันเหมือนมัน
แหลมๆแล้วมันเหมือนชี้ขึ้นข้างบนหรือ
เปล่าอันนี้ไม่รู้จริงๆนะไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
เพราะนี้ก็เดาแบบมั่วๆเลยใช่คือคุณนิเคย
ได้ยิน
ว่าถ้าจำไม่ผิดเนี่ยประเทศจีนเขาจะมองว่า
เลข 4 เป็นเลขไม่ดี
อืมอ๋อเคยเคยได้ยินเคยได้ยินว่า 4 มีมี
พูดหรือว่าออกเสียงคล้ายๆกับคำว่าตายใช่
คิดว่าอย่างงั้นอืเขคก็จะไม่ชอบ 4 ี่อะไร
เงี้ยเหรอ 4 น่าจะใช่มั้งคุณนิก็ไม่รู้
เกี่ยวกับภาษาจีนเลยอืขนาดคุณพ่อพ่อเป็น
คนจีนแต่เขาเป็นพูจีนแต้จีน 4 อ๋อสซี้ซี้
ตายอ้าซี้ซี้กันก็ดีสิอ้าวเหรอซี้ถ้าเกิด
ไทยก็เป็นซี้กันก็เป็นเพื่อนซี้เป็น
เพื่อนสนิทเอ้อใช่แต่ของคนจีนน่าจะแบบซี้
สี่ซี้ซี้แหงแก๋อย่างเงี้ยเหรอซี้อ่ะใช่
ซี้แหงแก๋แบบที่แปลว่าตายเออใช่ออใช่ๆๆ
เคยได้ยินว่ามีบางคนเนี่ยเวลาแบบมีรถใช่
มยมีรถเา้าก็จะมีป้ายทะเบียนรถอืไม่ให้มี
เลข 4 ครับอืมันหมายถึงแบบตายอืมอืนั่น
แหละเลข 4 แล้วก็มีอีกอันนี้แต่ว่าจริงๆ
อันนี้ก็คงจะไม่ค่อยได้เจอเยอะ
คือเหมือนกับฝรั่งนะบางคนเนี่ยหรือฝรั่ง
ที่หรือคนที่นับถือศาสนาคริสต์เนี่ยเขาจะ
ไม่ชอบเลข 6  3 ตัว 6  6  6 ใช่หรือว่าคน
ไทยพูดว่าตอง 6
ใช่เพราะมันมีเลขเดียวกัน 3 ตัวอืทำไมคะ
ครูนิกรู้มั้ย 66 เนี่ยที่ครูนิกได้ยิน
น่ะคือเขาบอกว่ามันเป็นเลขของ
ซาตานเออคือจริงๆก็เคยดูเคยเห็นหนังที่
เป็นเกี่ยวกับพวกหนังพวกผีฝรั่งหรือเป็น
เกี่ยวกับซาตานพวกยมทูตที่เขาอยู่ในอยู่
ในนรกเงี้ยเวลาในนรกใช่ถ้าถ้าทำไม่ดีก็จะ
เจอกับซาตานนั่นแหละเขาบอกว่ามันเป็นเลข
ที่เหมือนกับเรียกซาตานขึ้นมาอ๋อก็เหมือน
กับเป็นเลขเป็นเลขเรียกผีแบบนั้น
อือันนี้เราก็เป็นอะไรที่ไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
ว่าความเชื่อเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขนี้มาจากไหน
แต่หลายๆคนก็เชื่อเหมือนๆ
กันอืก็แต่ละที่เค้าก็จะมีความเชื่อที่
มันไม่เหมือนกันอืใช่เหมือนแบบเรียมกับ
ครูนิกเนี่ยก็แบบมีตัวเลขนำโชคหรือว่าตัว
เลขที่แบบทำให้เคเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
แบบโชคดีโชคไม่ดีที่มันอยู่ในความคิดของ
เราอ่ะนะไม่เหมือนกันเลยอือืนี่ตอนนี้
แล้วสำหรับนักเรียนล่ะคืออะไรตัวเลขอะไร
อืมคือตัวเลขอะไรคิดว่านักเรียนมาจากหลาย
ที่ก็น่าจะมีตัวเลข
ที่แตกต่างกันว่าชอบไม่ชอบโชคดีโชคไม่ดี
ใช่เพราะว่าแบบมาจากประเทศที่ไม่เหมือน
กันแล้วความเชื่อที่พ่อแม่บอกมาก็ไม่
เหมือนกันอ่ะช่วยมาเล่าเล่าให้ครูนี้กับ
ครูเรียมฟังเล่าให้ฟังหน่อยจะได้ดูเดี๋ยว
จะมาดูได้เลยอ่ะตอนเหมดเวลาจริงๆ
ละใช่เลยต้องลไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครูนิต้องไป
แล้วนะโอเคได้ไว้เจอกันใหม่โอเคครับใช่
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีค่ะครับเมครับ
บ๊ายบายบายครับ